I am getting ready to exit Tesla
sometimes when I say this people get mad
the build quality I am not hugely
impressed with rattles and Shakes and
I'm just not impressed with it I think
those other car companies that have been
making cars much longer that make better
cars the charging Network and the range
Tesla still has the advantage there but
the advantage is diminishing and when I
see Tesla dump prices the way they have
one perspective is this is a very bad
sign things must be going really
terribly for Tesla that they have to
drop prices so much the Counterpoint
I've seen is the fact that Tesla can
drop prices so much and still make money
confirms that their profit margins are
insane this is a sign that it's only the
beginning for Tesla which do you think
it is let me know in the comments